تبدو الاوضاع السياسيه مستقره هنا على عكس
ما كانت عليه قبل اشهر قليله لا تظاهرات
في الميدان والاعتصامات وهكذا يبدو الان
المكان الذي شهد مواجهات المسلحه قبل
تشكيل الحكومه
حكومه ولدت بعد مخاض عسير استمر اكثر من
عام لينتهي الامر بمشاركه اغلب القوه
التقليديه في تشكيلها باستثناء التيار
الصدري المنسحب من العمليات السياسيه
استقرار يبقى نسبيا في ظل ازمات كثيره
قائمه حتى الان وفي مقدمتها الاقتصاد
واعاهدكم ان اكون عونا للشعب العراقي سبق
ذلك تقاطعات وخلافات سياسيه حاده بعد حسم
نتائج الانتخابات التيار الصدري يشكل
تحالفا مع الحزب الديمقراطي الكردي وتحالف
السياده ممثلا لاغلبيه العرب السنه الاطار
التنسيقي والممثل لبقيه القوه السياسيه
الشيعيه يرفض مبدا الاغلبيه يفشل الصدر
حلفاؤه في تشكيل الحكومه لغياب التوافق
رغم حياذتهم الاغلبيه
واستحواذهم على كامل مناصبه هيئه رئاسه
البرلمانيك
نجم عن هذا الانسداد السياسي الذي وصل على
مرحله من حدوث كارثه همم ما بين القوى
السياسيه والتحول من لغه الحوار والتفاهم
الى لغه السلاح هذه النقطه الاساسيه
الخطره جدا التي كانت ان تعصب بالعراق على
مستوى السلم المجتمعي وتهدد الامن المواطن
العراقي بدرجه الاولى كانت البلاد وعلى
موعد مع احداث غير مسبوقه اعضاء الكتله
الصدريه يستقيلون من البرلمان وحلفاءهم
اخر من يعلم
قرار اقتحم على اثره الصدريون المنطقه
الخضراء ومقر البرلمان لساعات قبل
انسحابهم بتغريده من زعيمهم يتكرروا
المشهد بعد يومين لكن هذه المره بنيه
الاعتصام
اعتصام استمر لنحو شهر قابله اعتصام
المضاد لانصار الاطار التنسيقيه امام احدى
بوابات المنطقه الخضراء يرفض كل مطالب
الصدريين وبعد شهر اعلن الصدر استقالته
السياسيه
استقاله ان عقبها اقتحام انصاره القصر
الحكوميه هذه المره ليتدخل الامن ويخلي
القصر بكل الوسائل وبالرصاص احيانا يرد
الصدر يون بالسلاح ايضا
مواجهات داخل المنطقه الخضراء وعلى
اسوارها خلفت قتلى وجرحى من كلا الطرفين
الصدر يتدخل بعد اقل من 24 ساعه ويطالب
انصاره بالانسحاب وانهاء كل اشكال
الاحتجاج
حتى اذا لم ينسحب حتى من الاعتصام امام
البرلمان فانا ابرع حتى من التيار هدا
الشارع وبعد اكثر من شهر انتخب رئيس
الجمهوريه بالتصويت هذه المره لا بالتوافق
خلافا للاعراف وفي اليوم ذات الثالثه عشر
من اكتوبر كلف الرئيس الجديد محمد شياع
السوداني بتشكيل الحكومه باعتباره مرشح
لاطار التنسيقي الذي اضحك كتله النيابيه
الاكثر عددا وفي السابع والعشرين من
اكتوبر نالت تشكيله حكومه السوداني ثقه
البرلمان
سامر يوسف الجزيره بغداد